who's got the energy to be racist huh
that's gotta suck to be racist
wouldn't that be weird just like you go
to the bank you're like ah this
jew's here i gotta leave what a horrible
life
man put on an outfit go to a meeting all
that stuff
i don't care about any group enough to
hate it do it whatever you want go nuts
i don't i don't want to do anything i'm
lazy i don't want to burn a cross or a
calorie
yeah everybody's worked up on something
oh these
there's muslims on airplanes well i'd
rather a muslim on a plane than a baby
i've never had a muslim kick the back of
my seat and piss in the aisle
i'm just saying if the airport had a
baby ban i wouldn't protest
i was uh walking past a uh uh uh a
like a yoga spinning [__] people's
place and the door was open and i look
inside and this teacher this guy's
standing in front of a class and he's
just going like this
and he's going come on come on come on
joy come on and everybody all strangers
that don't know each other
are going like this and he's going come
on come on come on all right come on
and i thought what [__] power this
guy has
i wish i had that power over people even
without the conceit of a class wouldn't
it be great to be able to do that like
in an airport
a bunch of people waiting at a gate for
a plane it's like come on come on
come on everybody do this oh my god oh
[__] all right jesus why am i gonna have
to do this
it's [__] i'm late and i gotta
[__] do this
come on youtube come on
is how much time i spend alone on the
road man i actually spent so much time
on alone on the road actually like
contemplated milk
to the point i can't even [__] drink
it anymore
sitting there drinking like man stuff is
great tastes awesome you know then i
started thinking it comes out of the
carton and i just did the police work it
comes out of a cow and i'm like i am
[__]
suckling for another species
we have such a crazy relationship with
cows
you ever think about that no you can
nurse from it you can eat it
right you can tip it over when it's
sleeping but if you [__] it you're going
to jail
and i said this i didn't say it to him
but i said it in front of him so he
could hear i said i
[__] hate being poor and
my dad got really upset he didn't scream
or holler that wasn't his way
he just threw his newspaper on the floor
and he said david david david
you are not poor
he said poor is a mentality
[Music]
he said it's a mentality that very few
people ever recover from don't you
forget it son
you are broke
women time to fight for equality
brilliantly
right i mean brilliant 5 000 years
man we were fighting lions and tigers
and hunting buffalo
and when we were like we'll just pick
the berries you guys got that that's
you guys all right you guys are
brave look at wow
so courageous look at you hunting that
buffalo
second they put air conditioning in
office buildings women are like we want
equality
marks for it girls
just saying fellas if your relationship
ain't working right stop [__] your
woman to slow songs
[__] it do some gangster [__] as soon as
she walk in just
every day
many of you woke up and you realized you
were wrong
about everything you just you just woke
up you go god damn
i've been wrong about every single thing
i've ever believed
then it's time to go down to the rope
store in my opinion because
it's not going to get better you know
go to the rope store that's my
suggestion to you
and get a hunk of rope about this big
and then go to the rickety stool store
[Applause]
and listen it's no coincidence that the
rope store and the rickety stools are
always right beside each other right
i don't want to get political or
anything like that but
i would love to be gay i'll tell you why
because i'm a man's man
i like men men like me
we like each other i hate women
women hate me
we hate each other the only reason i
couldn't be gay is
because i could never [__] a man because
i could never [__] something that i
respect
i never get laid a couple weeks ago
finally that we had sex because it was
my birthday and she's like go ahead
so all right fine
i do not need her to be into it i just
want to get [__] annually laid that's
all i don't give a [__]
and it's always that's the fight i don't
feel like it you don't have to [__]
feel like it i don't give a [__]
and then we get into it now she feels
like it now she's invested in it now i'm
working for her again
somehow it's no longer this [__] for me
it's like about her
and that's great look i love her so i
always try like the last time i was
trying not to come really hard because i
like her [__] it i want to give her a
shot at it you know so
i'm trying
trying not to come very hard very hard
when you're ready to come
and you want to not come because of your
woman that is really hard
i don't know if women really appreciate
what goes into that [__]
the kind of stuff you got to think about
the thoughts you have to have because
the force you're fighting is the
universe
it's life on earth trying to march
forward
and you're trying to stop that [__] for
her
your body doesn't give a [__] you tell
your body hey hold up don't come your
body's like [__] you what are you
talking about
this is bigger than all of us here
and the only way to push that off is to
have terrible images and you're like
weird sick [__] up things in your head
you need them it's the only way she's
having a great time she's just off
thinking about flowers and puppies i
don't know
and the guy's thinking about like dog
[__] smeared on a dead guy or something
like that
in order to maintain her happiness
she's like passion and ecstasy and he's
like liza minnelli and richard nixon
having a diarrhea fight something i
don't know
but again that's what the world is like
people take everything personally i
think the
world revolves around them right
particularly on twitter
i don't know i'm not tweeting anyone i'm
just tweeting okay i don't know who's
following me
i've got 12 million followers i don't
know who's following me they can be
following me without me knowing
right choose to read my tweet and then
take that personally
that's like going into a town square
seeing a big notice board
and there's a notice guitar lessons and
you go
but i don't [__] want guitar lessons
what's this ah there's a number here
right call that right
are you giving me guitar lessons yeah i
don't [__] want any
fine it's not for you then just walk
away
don't worry about it no means no that's
another one no means no
it's like no it doesn't all right
look look no means no no that means no
all right but no
stop it what are you doing oh my god
you're being so bad stupid man
no yeah that's not a [__] no
that means i want to do it but i'm
afraid you're going to judge me
so i'm just going to make it look like
it was your idea so you don't figure out
that i've already performed this act
with 40 other [__] people
right but then
then you go to court and you get a bad
read there's some guy reading it
your honor she said no stop it what are
you doing you're being so bad
yeah and you just sent me like she
didn't [__] say it like that
she didn't say it like that like i can't
spell
if i had to spell restaurant
to this day right to save my mama's life
like if if
like if somebody held my mom a hostage
she had a gun to a head
right it says [__] spell restaurant you
know
shoot your mother in the head i'll be
like i would look at my mother like
uh i love you
you gotta look at me mom she's crying
understand that i i love you with all my
heart
stop stalling [__] okay all right all
right
all right
all right all right all right all right
r-s-t
oh my god here's where it gets
oh jesus christ
rowan
it's an a or you or you
all right give me another give me
another word man give me another word
one more word
just give my mother a chance to live
tomorrow
probably god dip banana all right banana
banana
b-a-n yeah yeah
and a-n-n-n
[Applause]
got a pretty crazy life man my father
was 70 years old when i was born
7-0 gets better
my mother was 32
here yeah
basically make me a product of loose
skin and loose morals if you look at it
like that
it's interesting growing up with a
father in his 70s because of the quality
time that we would spend
shortly after i was born my dad had one
of his strokes so
uh so we were both learning to walk at
the same time
we used to have little races for cookies
[Music]
soft batch
we'll play games like catch or don't
and my favorite is dad sleeping or is he
no longer with us
racism let's do that [__] huh come on if
you're racist and you know it clap your
hands
what the [__] bro what the hell
i i don't even
we know who you voted for
you know what's weird is two people
clapped one of them is brown one of them
is white how did that work
it'd be cool if they looked at each
other they were like
uh when i was at the grocery store i got
caught like in this weird
like thing with this dude so i was
standing in line and
i was behind this guy this white guy and
i
he pulled out the white race card now i
don't know if y'all knew we had a card
but he like had one so
[Applause]
i'm standing behind him and i just hear
him like argue like hear him just go
like uh what is it cause i'm white
is that why you're doing this because
i'm white and he looked at me like his
brother like hey are you gonna get
involved
you're gonna come on i was like sitting
there i was like no i
i'm not getting involved in this i'm not
ready for something
like this i think i think you're the
first guy ever to try this to be honest
with you
i'm not prepared at all if you wanted me
to help you you should have pulled me
aside earlier
you should have grabbed me like look i'm
gonna make history today do you be a
part of this or not
it's your call i went skiing recently
with my friend we're sitting on the ski
lift i was like why do you see more
black people skiing why is that
my friend has no idea but he's gonna you
know half-ass his way through it because
he don't want to see him dumb so he's
like ah you know
they don't grow up with it like well i'm
from louisiana i'm here
well skis very expensive ah right right
right yeah yeah you know i've never seen
a black guy with anything expensive on
their feet
just say you don't know it's all right
you sound way worse that's why black
people are smarter white people we do
crazy stuff we swim with sharks we go
bungee jumping cliff diving
ask a black guy why do they do that ago
i don't know that's why people [__]
that's a good answer they don't sit
around going uh you know europe
so i appreciate a good culture i
appreciate a good accent you got the
right accent you can get away with a lot
of [__]
you'll be in a club and say something
foul to a woman an american accent she
might slap the [__] out of you
like excuse me baby i don't mean to
bother you but you got a fat ass
i love to take you home [__] the [__]
out you [__]
english accent that just roll off the
tongue different excuse me i don't mean
to bother you
but i really love to take you back to my
hotel if you dog yourself a little bit
you know i mean
[__] where you from
oh my god say something else
ladies you're laughing some of the
fellas might try that on the way home
do you have a good time at the comedy
show tonight is it really
the next light because you give me a
little bit of head just a little bit
i don't want much just want you to
polish me now if you know what i'm like
i ain't even gonna lie i'll use that
[__] to get some [__] i walk up to a
woman and say anything
excuse me you know what time it is oh my
god your accent is beautiful where are
you from
i just make [__] up mcdonald's england
have you ever heard of it
i live right over at mcmuffin lane have
you ever had
oh my god girl you live my bag
i tell you what accent is not sexy is
that east indian accent that's 7-eleven
[__] that turban [__]
that dot towel [__] ladies trust me you
do not want that on top of you on a
saturday night
i'm going to give it to you i know you
wanted your dirty [__] and i
wanted i'm going to give you my pakasani
beef you [__]
say my name say puma sanji pumasanji
[Music]
and why is mcdonald's still counting
this is really insecure isn't it
40 000 80 million zillion billion
killian tell you
what what what is this does it mean
anything to anyone 89 billion sold
okay i'll have one
i would love to meet the chairman of the
board of mcdonald's just say to him look
we all
get it you've sold
a lot of hamburgers whatever the hell
the number is
just put up a sign mcdonald's we're
doing very well
i don't need to hear about every goddamn
one of them
what is their ultimate goal to have cows
just surrendering voluntarily or
something
showing up at the door we like to turn
ourselves in we see the sign
we realize we have very little chance
out there
[__] i need alibaba i can't be no
celebrity this [__] is just the worst
i'm seeing it i can see why i see why
stars are crazy man these [__]
i went to disney world with my kids
which is a big deal for me i get to see
my kids so much
i do chappelle show 20 hours a day sleep
for like half an hour raise my kids for
20 minutes and i go back to work now
this particular day i got to hook up
with the kids we went to disney world
everybody at the park [__] everybody
hey hey rick james [__]
hey i'm rick james [__]
it's like hey man hey you might not call
me a [__] in front of my kids
time out [__] we take a day off
even mickey mouse did it i said this is
the most unprofessional [__] i have ever
seen in my life
we're dreams [__] oh i was fed up
i caught that [__] with the
uppercut
knocked his head clean off everybody was
screaming oh my god
oh my god mickey mouse is mexican
no it's great though my father told me
when i was a kid he said you're not
going to know what it is to be a real
man
until you hold a tiny baby in your arms
and i didn't understand that then but i
do now because
i held my baby my arms and i felt like a
real man you know because i could crush
i was on a plane the other day i
actually had the urge to elbow an old
lady in the face
it was like compelling was unbelievable
you know when you go to get off a plane
there's like rules
when you go to get off the plane all
right it goes row by row by row and this
lady was all like oh i'm 90.
i get to cut everybody right so i'm
competitive i start [__] boxing her
out right
start bringing down like the overhead
luggage you know so she just starts like
waddling around me and all of a sudden i
just feel my elbow like dude you're
gonna take this [__]
this is ridiculous man the whole half of
the plane is watching it come on man
come on
dude we got a wide open shot just just
just real life
you don't get to hit it that hard and
then you can play it off
i'm literally talking to my elbow like
dude come on man we can't do this [__]
all right
this trick's like 95 years old we can't
do it i thought i had my body under
control and she got like to right about
there and then i felt my foot like dude
we could still trip her
it's still tripping he's throwing that
out there if you want to learn about
nature you watch
discovery channel or one of these you
know nature programs where they have a
guy
on safari and he's studying from afar
crocodile hunter and all come on every
episode
hey all you doing look over there
right there it's a tiger
and tiger weighs 800 pounds and it could
kill a man in 10 seconds
i'm going to touch it
[Applause]
he's angry he's angry
next episode ah that's a king cobra the
most venomous snorkeling all the planet
one point i'm dead i'm gonna pick it up
he's angry
if he really wanted people to think he
was out there man america we should have
borrowed him
and sent him to iraq with no gun just a
camera crew
you imagine how bad that would have
freaked out the enemy you know you're
freaking
a soldier working for al qaeda and
you're out there you know
and he's walking towards them wearing
shorts
[Applause]
an iraqi soldier one of the most
dangerous creatures in all the planet
one push of a button and i'm gone
i'm gonna poke him with a stick
so i'm totally pro teachers [__] kids
i'll tell you what look i'm very
i'm not okay with it i'm pro i'm
doubling down
i'm doubling down on it i'll tell you
why
i looked up these little psychos that
shoot up the schools you know these
little psychopaths
right every single one of them said they
did it for the same reason
not because of bullying by the way they
said they did it because they weren't
getting late
we got a question we need to ask
ourselves guys
are these teachers monsters are they
heroes
forget no child left behind suck a dick
save a school
that's a slogan yes yes
we got to keep our babies safe
we got any female teachers in the
audience tonight
i hope you're willing to go the extra
mile
i'm not joking you see a weird kid
during lunch you know the weird kid the
kid whose jeans don't touch his sneakers
you see one of those hovering jeans kids
in the corner twisting a squirrel's head
off his shoulders
[Laughter]
suck that kid's dick
empty balls make safe halls
[Applause]
white people that's why i study our envy
arm i'm envious to y'all y'all a race
y'all do whatever the [__]
y'all want to do y'all you know y'all
are free you're only only racing people
that could look at a wild lion
and go i can be friends with that
that's why y'all are always on when
animals attack you will never see black
people
or when animals attack you might see us
on when cops attack
but she would never see us on an
animal's attack
y'all would do [__] like tranquilize a
lion and hold that [__] till he
wake up and that'd be heavy [__] to
y'all y'all be in the camera
[Music]
well my partner bob and i
we've been tracking this particular
beast for quite some time
her name is otulu she's six months old
we just shot her with five cc's of
textual coeur d'alene darts
when she gets up she's gonna be [__]
pissed
oh my god bombed you for your heart
pounding this is amazing
oh my god she's getting a plow she
molded me what an experience
the africans don't be out there [__]
with the lions they ask them mr matumbu
why you don't play with the lion i'm not
[__] with that [__]
[__] him and [__] you that [__] is not
in the brochure i'm not doing that [__]
when my shift is over i want to go home
to my children mangulu mangala and
i can't do it [__] with that when the
[__] around you better come i will leave
you in the car
hi noah
i don't know if you're affected by the
volcanic ash cloud um but i had friends
that were stuck all over
the world and they missed weddings and
funerals and they had to put themselves
up in a hotel for
extra days that i hadn't budgeted for
and they couldn't get their money back
because the airlines were saying no we
can't pay you
because the insurance companies won't
pay us because they're saying it's an
act of god
what isn't an act of god no
if you believe in god that's sort of a
definition of him isn't it
that he does everything isn't that right
everything is an axe of him he's
all-powerful
he's everywhere at one he invented it
there was nothing before him he invented
time everything he's across
it all okay he doesn't miss a trick and
he's not absent-minded a volcano going
off isn't like him going [__] i left the
oven on
you know it's
i know these insurance companies that
can decide what is and isn't an act of
god how do they know okay have they got
a hotline to god
they call him up do they ring-ring
ring-ring
hello uh could i speak to god please
speaking oh i didn't think you'd answer
the phone yourself
what you want oh um
that volcanic ash cloud uh was that you
yeah yes that was an act of me all right
so i shouldn't pay out no don't [__]
pay my penny son no
brilliant brilliant while i've got you
here um did you make a tree fall on
steve baxter's car
there's a lot of steve baxter's um steve
baxter to acacia road
houndslow it happened at 2 15 on the
third of june this year
2 15 3rd no that wasn't me
i was in africa that day giving aids to
babies
i'm trying to like make it so women just
like understand a little bit of like
just to sympathize
it's like we're like sport fishermen
that's what i'm saying
men like to fish and sport fishing is
different from catching
fish for food you just get it you get it
you catch it
and you you know you you show your
friends
because you want them to know that you
you can catch fish
you take a couple of pictures so you can
show people to fish
that you have the ability to
and then you release it back into the
water
but a lot of women in here you have
boyfriends or husbands
you a fish that jump back on the boat
and just was like flapping looking at me
like
hi i was wondering if you're gonna be
fishing here again next week like
yeah for other fish get off my boat
is that how you treat all the fish you
be like oh
god damn nope i'm sorry sweetie you're
the last fish i ever wanted to be with
now you stuck
stuck with the last fish who was loving
you and fighting hard to be on your boat
then she got comfortable and now instead
of doing this she's like so
we've been together for like
a year now why do you still have a boat
he's like
so what's he trying to say i can't catch
fish no more why are you to catch a fish
because if i lose my ability to catch
fish then you're not gonna find me sexy
no more so you gotta smell
fish on me so that you know i can catch
fish so you can act right
that's like guys you meet your girl she
was a hoe
like had whole like she big old booty
and this and that
you got to let her do that don't start
trying to trump her up and get a fat and
get a foul
because that's why you like her i don't
want no woman that
no other guy is trying to i don't want a
woman
that i can send to the store at two in
the morning
cause nobody's going to try to rape her
like i go
go get some bread at three in the
morning hey cut through the alley [__]
because
cause i talked to the junkies they don't
want it dang guys they don't like you
remember it's three o'clock in the
morning it's three o'clock in the
morning
i look out the window
it was a [__] baby standing on the
corner
and the baby the baby didn't even look
scared he was just standing there
i mean it made me sad it made me say it
really good you know because i want to
help the baby
i don't trust you either i'm sorry click
the old baby on the corner trick eh
you're not gonna fall for that [__]
where's this limousine driver you know i
stopped feeling bad
as time goes by i start feeling worse
like man what is wrong with me what the
hell is wrong i am scared of a baby
and this baby could be in trouble he
might need my help i got to do something
but i wasn't going to get out the car
serious man i just cracked the window a
little bit
there's a whole limousine i can roll it
[Applause]
down
hey baby baby go home man it's three
o'clock in the morning what the [__] are
you doing now
[Applause]
the baby said i'm selling weed [__] at
home
[Applause]
i wasn't expecting that
i'm sorry i had to buy two bags from the
coma they're gonna get two when i get
too funny
[Applause]
got back in the car and rolled me a
joint man that [__] was scary man
every once in a while like a crack kid
would come up to the car and look in the
window it was like jurassic park and
should he be looking on the car
hey get out of here cracky
[Applause]
that baby was still standing there man
what it is
that's not feeling bad again yeah we
make you feel guilty sometimes you know
man what is wrong with me man i have
just brought weed from from an infant
i can't condone this kind of behavior
what am i thinking i can't let the fear
ruin my morals
got to do something
hey baby stop selling wheat all right
you got your whole life ahead of you
he said [__] you [__] i got kids to
feed that's a god
trump i remember
when he said if you're a billionaire
women let you grab them by the [__]
checks out i don't don't get me wrong i
know there's women in here who are like
that's [__] up that's [__]
i would never allow that and to you i
would say
you've never met a billionaire
he's got nothing to do with you you're
out there getting fingered by
thousands
it's a different demographic
and frankly i agree with you a thousand
there should ask you permission
before he puts his minimum wage fingers
in your [__] that's disgusting that's
why your [__] smells like wendy's
but a billionaire let him grab your
[__]
a billionaire grabs your [__] that's
the best thing that's happened to you in
your life
you're gonna sue that guy and now you're
a millionaire
fastest million dollars you've ever made
okay you know how many billionaires
there are in the world
it's like a hundred any one of them
could grab my
dick anywhere
let bill gates walk up to me right now
grab my dick i'll grab his wrists and
hold that [__] dad
yeah bill i'll show you microsoft
[Music]
look
[Applause]
[Music]
so i've done uh i did a show in a prison
once
all the way in it we went in it there's
a little
a few more people than this we go in
let's say
like you guys are like the inmates so
i'm like sitting here
doing my dumb jokes none of them work
every joke i have involves being outside
the past 30 years like nothing's
relatable i'm like traffic's crazy do
you guys remember who remembers traffic
a lot has changed el paso a lot has
changed
one thing's for sure i'm still the
fluffy guy
[Applause]
and i say fluffy because that is the
politically correct term for those of
you that don't remember
i used to say that there were five
levels of fatness
reason why i say used to say is because
now there are six
i met the new one in las cruces
[Applause]
the original five levels are big healthy
husky fluffy and damn
people ask what could be bigger than
damn
the new level called oh hell no
what's the difference you're still
willing to work with level five
example if you're on an elevator and
you're with your friend and this really
big guy gets on and you and your friend
look at each other and you're like
damn but you still let the big guy ride
your elevator
that's the difference level six you see
walking towards your elevator
[Applause]
oh hell now
so yeah my wife and i got in a big fight
today because
um she says i don't listen to her
and i don't but
it's not because i don't love her blah
blah blah
it's because she sucks at talking i
swear to god
she sucks at it when she starts telling
a story
it immediately turns into another like
she takes every story and divides it
into 50 stories that each branch out
in the encyclopedias about other stories
and i try because i love her when she
starts talking i'm like i'm locked in
i'm going to listen to the whole thing
but somehow i just
did i can't i drift i can't do it
every story she's like oh you know when
my sister was in college
not when she went to antioch you know
how she transferred because of that you
know because that guy that got weird
not the little guy the guy with a beard
you know the thing
i think he was right what are you
talking about
pick a thing
that's what i do i go here's the story
when i tell it i bought a tomato
and i ate it and it was good anyone can
follow that story
it was about a tomato the whole time
this one time racism saved my life man i
was i was on a plane
i was coming i was coming from overseas
and uh i don't know how this guy got a
machine gun on the plane but he stood up
man he said
everybody get on the [__] ground
nobody look at my face
i started freaking out because he was
chinese i was like why is he talking
like
he that screaming and crying
i was the only brother on the plane i
thought i was younger brother i looked
over there was one other black dude he
was from nigeria
i i looked over at him he was looking
right in my face man he didn't say two
words to me just looked at him he was
like
he didn't need to talk i know just what
he's talking about i look right back at
him
some of my dudes on the front of the
plane cena say we're like oh my god
i think those black guys are gonna try
to save us
we were just communicating that we
understood the situation
we were both seeing the same thing what
we understood was simple
terrorists don't take black hostages
that's the truth i have yet to see one
of us
on the news reading the hostage letters
um they is treating us good
uh we all chilling and [__]
i'd like to give a shout out to ray ray
and big steve and
send some
i hope somebody takes a [__] beer
stein and just
slaps you on the back of your zit
infested [__]
shoulders and your awful man tip tank
tops
i hope that happens to you hope the
glass [__] digs into your [__]
shoulder blade
and then i see you afterwards hey how's
it going enjoy the [__] show that's
great and i grab you by the [__] hair
but you don't have any
i really hope all of you run into all
those black people that you love so much
here
i really hope that happens i hope
there's a line of all of you guys
getting [__] carjacked
they take out their big black dicks and
they just shove them right in your
[__] mouth
each and every one of you and somehow
they just keep repeatingly coming
right
[Music]
left
[Applause]